you
blow to my house mines is her father is
jamaican her mother German her stage
name sounds English but Lori sings in
German does fish undesirables to entitle
it was a conscious decision to sing in
German and it has to be because you're
setting limits on yourself well that's
what everyone says at least you don't
consider it they say ok you can see in
German but you'll never make it big
inflation that may or may not be true i
don't know but i like the German
language sheesh mark d daughters
parklands Afghan Laurie has given a name
to her style of music future Deutsche
Welle that's also the name of her debut
album Born Larissa's Sarah harden Lara
moved to Berlin for years ago she comes
from the town of Gelsenkirchen and has
made the German capital her home
Larry lived for a while in New York City
that's where she decided to pursue a
career in music she self produced her
first song two years ago the video for
bedtime blues was shot with friends in a
basement Young's above item blood can
mama been a July on my bench under mine
geezers force kuvira five all ways been
sure of myself even as a kid I was
raised that way my parents and family
gave me so much love and support so I
never asked myself if I was okay not
obviously well the way you are so I'm do
your things persistent must ending and
it's clobber does kind of an Aston Villa
can be a bit off-putting at first no but
yeah for me especially for men on her
self confident attitude might bother
some but she doesn't mind Larry sang in
her first musical at the age of 11 she
kept on singing and making music and
eventually she discovered her love of
writing the 28 year old now shares her
thoughts feelings and experiences on her
blog and on other social media and she's
always busy working on her soft
Larry likes to play the lascivious
seductress like here in the video too
young and shown the first single off her
debut album twins Arabella cement I'm a
very physical and sexual person in a
totally natural way so it's no big deal
Anderson big deer though as soon as I'm
a woman I like my body and I'd like to
show it off that's totally normal to me
sexy clever and talented Laurie a rising
star in Germany's pop music scene